hello there reject nation I'm Greg album
I'm John Humphrey I'm Sally Sally
Lomonaco is with us she just showed up
two and a half minutes ago and I said
you're watching the shaft trailer she is
not familiar with the shaft franchise
and I said even better I warned her the
shaft fandom is one serious ass but now
I mean chef has their films very spread
out and you want to be able to hook
newcomers into the franchise so I always
feel like it's actually a fun experiment
when you have people who are familiar
with the shaft franchise Jean and I
being the biggest of them all oh yeah
I'm a chef tattoo and Sally is not that
fair so I quickly explain to her what
the shaft franchise is now let's see
what you think my dear you must have
heard the song we'll see probably you in
city know what kind of business good
just done I'm gonna have in my will need
your help for a case to read you smile
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
for you guys who don't know he was doing
an interview I think with Sam Rubin and
Sam Rubin said talked about the Super
Bowl commercials Sam Jackson's in but it
wasn't Sam Jackson it was Laurence
Fishburne and Sam Jackson pretty much
tore him a new one during that interview
oh you know what I've been my mistake I
give you you're as crazy as the people
on Twitter
I'm not Laurence Fishburne that's my
fault
I know that was my fault we don't all
look alike
and famous you are guilty I am guilty I
was so happy to to hear that Sally will
you go watch shaft yeah this movie is
made for young white females how was it
to you I would love to like get a little
tipsy this movie it looks good I'm
really excited to see him like in a
full-on comedy because he's really funny
you know it's it's I know he was in the
hit man's bodyguard but he seems like
he's letting a lot more loose here which
is always a delight to see these whole
passing the baton kind of movies always
sound off-putting whenever I hear a
description of it and usually they are
yeah yeah I mean it kind of started
there and then other movies like why
would you learned your lesson this the
chemistry between him and the guy
playing shafts kid John shaft junior
Jesse tea uh sure their chemistry just
looks so much fun I love how he's the
antithesis to the shaft personality
because you got the Richard Roundtree
shaft the og shaft and you got Sam
Jackson shaft which is not far off from
Richard Roundtree and then you have the
Sun nothing like attracting like the
Millennial like our generation mix of
Samuel Jackson I think that's me so much
see Sally you thought that you wouldn't
know what to say but you already got
plenty I put that in your mouth in a
night I was serious as to why and that
one scene at first they there's a red
band trailer there's lots of swearing
and yet they cut it right before she
says you think just could you walk
around he's smelling good because you
got a big [ __ ] they put in the shaft
it was like perfect
meta censorship Regina Hall looks
hilarious in this too I'm really psyched
that she's like back in action in a big
way it seems like she's been getting it
lately yeah an Alexandra ship coming off
of the high that Dark Phoenix is gonna
have this weekend I'm so happy for her
to be in this another slight meta joke
about the N word he's been interviewed
plenty of time Sam Jackson about the
usage of the n-word for in the Tarantino
movies because he's in most of those
Tarantino flicks and like I remember
hearing about how DiCaprio on Django was
so uncomfortable to Satan he was like
it's just a word just say oh I don't
want to say it why not I don't like to
say it have you ever said no sir
try it I don't try it really we're not
gonna have this conversation unless you
say it won't move on to another question
okay I don't I don't like I don't want
to say come on Kenny boy you say it no
[ __ ] no why do you gotta bleep it when
you say it I'll say it so I feel like
that's kind of a slight meta commentary
about it too because this shaft movie is
obviously gonna be the most meta of them
the most self-aware I don't know about
meta but the most self-aware at all yeah
mostly now I'm just actually curious
about what this movie is truly gonna be
about because I feel like this trailer
is very bit heavy very chemistry heavy
very humor heavy and I guess that's the
ultimate point of this shaft adventure
but still I mean no I sure I mainly show
up for a shaft movie for the intricate
nuanced details the adventure and the
exploration of New York City or when
shaft goes to Africa that was another oh
yeah a good one I'm really elevated the
franchise you should start with that one
it makes me want to watch the other
movies they're all especially the first
three they're all just this idea sounds
like it shouldn't worry but it seems
like it's really working
that's it's no weird about it I knew
what type of movie they wanted to do and
then just commit it because the first
three are black exploitation the the one
with Sam Jackson and Christian Bale is
like kind of unintentionally cheesy I
don't feel like it was fully intentional
this seems like it it knows exactly what
it's going out
do yeah it seems like they know exactly
which lane to pick in this day nation
you know to bring back shaft because
also I mean times have very much changed
and so to bring back blaxploitation now
I feel like you have to have some kind
of self aware and and also I mean like
it's neat that you know this franchise
has been picked up so much over time and
has been a lot of age and has been
allowed to kind of adapt to the world
around it so like that can be tricky I
feel like you know like having
millennial stuff but um at least judging
by these trailers again the blend looks
pretty appealing to me so I just hope
this is a ton of fun absolutely man
absolutely alright guys well are you
excited for shaft which has had two
trailers and comes out next week we're
confident in this movie let's find out
you know what John's doing for his
birthday
watching shaft yeah you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hey if you like this
video thumbs up that bad boy follows
Sally on her channel she just put up a
video recently if you like Bob Ross and
comedy go check it out kind of weird but
I had enjoyed the hell out of it
also I wanted to give a patron of the
day shout out to Luke Anderson
Luke Anderson I've been saying this for
like for shout outs in a row now where
the f have you been you [ __ ] I've been
trying to contact you on patreon
messages for so long you and I had such
good rapport for a while and now you
just disappeared kept your credit card
on file I like money money makes me
happy but once I asked you to send me a
picture of your shaft for some reason
you ghosting me man what the hell is
your problem what exactly is a shaft
well you know there are a few
definitions if you want to get technical
about it
send me your shaft showing that were
okay take care guys
you